Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome
back to "60 Seconds".
Now, I realise what I was doing wrong in the other
episode and it's- it's not
entirely obvious what I was doing wrong.
It is simply a matter of fact
that
I
didn't give up
my fricking...
thing
that I needed to give up
and I know I didn't  but it was not my
fault because they're stupid and...
I...I needed to give up my gun and I'm
actually talking kinda in a sporastic
way because I need to get the things that I need
to geeeeeet... and we're gonna
GEEEEET
'em!
Druh-buh-buh
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh go go go
go go go go go go go go go go rab-a-dub
rab-a-dab rab-a-dab rab-a-dab rab-a-dab
rab-a-dab rab-a-dab rab-a-dab
Get wife!
Get in mah pocket! Please! I need you
Eeeeeehhhhh! Inside
of meeee!
Okay.
Get the daughter. Why's the daughter gotta be so big
Maybe I could just forget about the daughter for now
Aw why's that take up two spots!?
Oh dammit dammit dammit dammit I needed more water
I needed more water i don't even have the MAAP
WHERE'S THE GODDAMN MAAAP?
Oh crap where's the maaap?
Crap! Oh crap oh crap oh crap!
Oh come on!
Did I get the map?
Did I get it? I don't know if I got it.
Did I get it? I don't remember. I don't remember anything I got
My mind totally blanks out there
What did I get?
Day one
Crap!
Okay, I got the map, I got the scout manual,
I got the briefcase, I got... Okay! We're good.
Okay. We're good. We're good.
Okay, this is actually OK
All of us made it in. We've got one extra can of soup
We've got ANOTHER extra can of soup. We've got plenty cans of soup
Because apparently I didn't grab any soup!
But we're fiiiiiine!
Okay...
We're gonna make it this time.
We're gonna go on a butt-load of expeditions,
We're only gonna cure people when they need to be cured,
We're gonna make sure that people don't go insane.
This is gonna be the one! I can definetly feel it.
I can feel it my bones
I can feel it in my butt
They gave us an axe! Nice! Okay. Good
Good good good good good.
No expeditions just yet. Oh we could go on an expedition
because we... No it's too dangerous to go on an expedititon
We're not gonna make 'em go on an expedition
We're not gonna do that 'till after the radiation clears up
because we got enough food to be able to last us a while.
Why is the gun an option?
that was like the fun screen.
Like, 'Let's do something fun!'
And the GUN was an option!
That has some very serious implications
that I don't...ooh okay...
So...
I'm gonna prep for a trip
and then everyone's gonna get fed tomorrow
And then, someone's gonna go outside
because I think the radiation has died down
but just in case,
'Great news! The fallout outside is mostly gone. It should be much safer to travel on the surface now.
thats good
Everyone gets supplies, and then Dolores,
who is a CHAMPION
is gonna go out there and its gonna be just fine
She's gonna go with the gas mask
because I believe I'm not
100% sure on this one but I believe the gas mask
will help her fight
off any diseases.
I don't even know how we get diseases down here, unless we're all
breathing in fumes from the bucket n'
takin' bucket baths,
which is gonna be BAD!
Let's see... 'We should probably keep busy with something
to keep us occupied before it gets worse.'
Let's see... 'We did! the photo we were'-
Okay, apparently...
Apparently, we were looking for a photo of
a relative and we... kept it in the pages
of the Boy Scout- I'm assuming that keeps
us from going insane,
and that's good. 'If we care about the future of
our kids, we need to start homeschooling Timmy- or maybe
shelter-schooling is the right choice of words. We need to provide
him with some reading material as soon as possible.'
Boy Scout Handbook sounds good!
As long as he doesn't start rippin' pages out and makin' paper aeroplanes
out of 'em
We're gon' be GOOD!
YEE HAW!
We're gon' be good. He might learn a thing or two.
PERFECT!
Readin's
BRILLIANT!
GREAT!
Oh no...
[DRAMATIC TENSION]
OH NO!
DON'T SHOOT THE DOGGY!
Do it- can I do nothing?
I don't wanna shoot the doggy!
...I don't wanna shoot the doggy...
Maybe I don't need to do nothin'!
But it could be a hungry dog...
It's gonna be bad
[MATING CALL]
[GUN SHOT]
[DOOR OPENING]
AAAAH!
[measly wimper]
'A quick shot was more than enough to scare it away or maybe bring down whatever dark creature stalked us in the darkness.
We never saw it again.
[CHILDISH WAIL]
IT WAS THE PUPPY!
Aw, '...stumbled upon the ruins of a familiar building-
Our local bank.'
*Sigh of acceptance*
'It looks like the bank was robbed just before the blast.
The vault was cracked open with saws hidden in teddy bears'
but ♫FOUR♫
Cans of food, one can o' water
and we lost the gas mask.
That's okay...
Everyone gets fed today,
and we're still on schedule.
We do...
Oh.
Phone call?
Timmy,
Go get the phone please.
Don't go crazy and don't get sick.
PLEASE
[DOOR OPENING]
DO NOT GO CRAZY,
DO NOT GET SICK, YOU ST- Okay good.
Good. Okay, we neeeed...
Someone to go outside for supplies.
We don't have a gas mask for him, but...
We do what we can.
Mary-Jane's tough as a brick.
Mary-Jane is
TOUGH
AS
BRICKS.
So Mary-Jane's gonna take the axe.
And NOTHIN'
'Aint nothin' gonna mess with Mary-Jane.
Mary-Jane is a TROOPER.
She is a trooper, and she will
get us what we need.
Alright.
I believe in her.
Yes, Okay, PERFECT!
Government wants co-ordinates,
I'll give 'em co-ordinates.
They need co-ordinates,
I got 'em co-ordinates
We need water, though.
I really hope Mary-Jane comes back with water.
We need water, like, BAD.
Okay,
'Strange noises in our pipes, ha-'
-'Check,
Hellish'-
-'Yells outside, oh Dolores hasn't spoken for a while.'
'That's it.'
'And it's really strange. Talking to her would be a good idea.'
Yeah!
Talk to your wife, man!
Talk to your wife!
TALK TO YOUR WIFE!
Why wouldn't 'cha talk to your wife?
Why wouldn't 'cha talk to yer wife?
'Talking to Dolores helped resolve some of her issues and doubts.
She feels better now.'
Okay good.
And everyone gets fed...
...And water'd...
'Someone's at the door. We're a bit scared'...
Fff...
'Maybe it's a friendly face of an American soldier.
Should we open it?'
I DON'T SEE WHY NOT
What are they gonna do?
Take our WATER away from us?
[RAPID LAUGHS]
Oh good she's not sick.
Hey, we got some poison control!
'...Opened the hatch...Nobody there... damn pranksters'
'Makin' jokes even after the apocalypse.'
We got our axe back!
We got TWO soups,
We got TWO waters,
We got ONE poison...
MARY-JANE, YOU'RE A CHAMPION!
YEAH!
YUS
Okay, so Mary-Jane's gonna get fed
right now, and then I'm just gonna pick it all
back up on 25.
That's what I should have been doing...
Alone.
Okay...
So...
We're OK for now.
Wait, how many...
..How many... We have three bottles of water.
That's enough to last 15 more days.
I don't wanna sen- Wha- We could send Timmy out.
We- We COULD send Timmy out.
I think it'd be fine...
...If we did that...
OOH!
'Today we were visited by a strange-looking man'
'Who introduced himself as a trader.'
'He insisted his price...' Okay.
So...
Gas mask for ammo, we don't have...
...Either of those...
...Checkerboard for a flashlight...
Do we need a flashlight?
We could get a bottle o' water out of this.
I'm down for a bottle of water because
frankly, I don't know what the...
...Suitcase is gonna do for me.
I really don't know.
I really have no idea.
Alright...
Alright, Timmy...
Imonna- Imonna let you go with the bug spray?
Dammit
Because that's worked in the past
where he just so happens to come a cross a giant...
...HORRIBLE
HORRIBLE assembly of bugs.
[DOOR OPENS]
You go Timmy you GOT IT
Timmy's the man!
Timmy's... probably not the man.
Mary-Jane's the man.
'Some friendly soul on the radio was talking about a'
'supply pack.' She lost
TWO WATERS, ONE
FOOOOOOOOD!
YEAH!
We won't need to send anyone else
If Timmy doesn't even come back,
It's actually
FINE.
This might be the one!
Unless some horrible thing happens,
which it always does!
*Manly sigh*
Alright...
'We decided to act out scenes from our favorite movies...' Okay.
goodgoodgoodgoodgood...
Whatever. Good for you guys.
Just no one...
Go crazy.
NO ONE GO CRAZY
Timmy, come BACK.
Come back to us, Timmy!
TIMMY COME BACK!
*Inhalation of anticipation*
♫Tim-mi-come-back-please.♫
♫We♫
♫Love-you♫
♫It-is-rea-lly-lone-ly-here♫
Okay... 'The radio of ours has been silent for the past few hours,'
'We need our news, we need our music,'
'We all agreed...'
'We need to meddle with it, until it works.'
NO!
DON'T MEDDLE WITH IT!
DON'T MEDDLE!
Please, no one go crazy...
*Inhalation of risk*
YES!
AHHH!
*success noise*
That would've been bad if you
doodoodidadoo
You would've been bad if you
widadoodoodoo...
Okay...
Everything's fine...
...No one's gonna go crazy...
...Everyone is A-OK...
'We're a regular family, so...'
'...arguments never got intense as the fight we just go on into-'
'No one wants to speak to each other.'
'Let's just hope this won't last too long'.
No!
Don't do that!
Don't DO that!
There's Timmy?
YES! Everyone's still-
-Not crazy!
Oh, and Timmy brought back a lot of stuff.
He brought back the...
...Stuff...
...The poison,
He got a can o' soup,
'...canteen...respectable tomato soup...'
Okay...
[PAGE TURNING
...And two cans o' water
AND THEN
TWO MORE CANS O' SOUP!
We are
FINE
We are a 100% fine
Timmy, you eat up
Because
Then we'll just all eat on the 30th
and
Everything'll be fine
'Note on our door today was a real surprise,'
'it was not signed and said whoever wrote it was'
Observing
'us for right kind of people. They sent us to...'
'... send a signal. Unarmed representative to meeting today'
'to find out more. Should we send someone?'
Mary-Jane looks in good shape but I don't wanna... really wanna
lose her
Okay she's back
Okay. Alright. We're okay. Right
'The meeting was organized by twin s...' Okay so that was the twins
That was the twins. Totally okay
Everything's fine
We're all gonna eat tomorrow
We're not going on anymore expeditions
'Where is a ball when you need one'
'We got a little bored and need something to occupy ourselves'
'Too many'
'hours of counting pipe droplets'
Cards
Good enogh
Good enough.
Cards are good
Okay
Everyone's gonna eat
Everyone's gonna eat 'cause frankly
We did- We did good
We deserve this
And we don't need to go out yet
until things get a little more desperate
We're fine
Everything's fine
I'm like
Oh god everyone does not look fine
Everyone looks horrible
'We're trying out bes to remain calm. The situation we're in is far from normal'
'We might never get used to it. We hope the help comes soon'
'Mary-Jane's pretty fatigued'
Why is Mary-Jane fatigued?
Why is Mary-Jane fatigued? Wh-What happened to  Mary-Jane?
Whta happened to Mary-Jane?
'Claiming they're willing to offer a lot for decent ammunition'
All I got is a cheker board
but I have cards.
So I can sacrifice the checkerboards.
Because I have cards. Depending on what he gives us.
Huh?
'We offered checkres instead of ammunition'
'and tried to explain what ammunintion is'
'We pretended to understand nothing... very... left che-'
What?
What? He didn't give us anything
What was the point of that?
I didn't know that's how it was gonna go!
Son of a biiitch!
Son of an aaass!
'Open in the name of freedom, came a shout from outside of our door'
'We weren't sure who claimed to be representing freedom'
'But we could hear it was a group of people, probably armed'
'Anybody who introduces themselves like that'
'is probably planning to kill someone in the name of freedom.'
'Should we open it?'
Imma look this one up
Okay, so apparently
'You may be visited by a band of armed,'
'dark-faced teenagers who are fighting in the name of freedom.'
'And ask if you're with the Reds'
'communists'
'And reveal themselves to be called Wolverines'
This is a reference to the movie Red Dawn'
'When a band of high school students armed'
'And call themselves Wolverines'
'after their high school mascot'
'when a communist invasion occurs in America.'
So
That sounds like they're fighting against the communists
Which means that
we're
gonna let 'em iiiiiiiin
Come on in, buddies!
That better not have gone bad for me.
Everyone's still alive!
Good.
What did they do?
'We regretted opening the door the minute- we-'
'-saw who was standing on the other side.'
'Dark faces, rifles and determined looks of band of teenagers'
'We're doomed, we thought.'
'Then out of the blue, one of them asked us if we're with the Reds.'
'We never supported the Red Sox'
'so we cont- haha-confidently said that we weren't.'
'The tension dropped immediately'
'And those nice young people gave two bottles of water!'
'They told us to have no fear, since the Wolverines were around
[Inhale of success]
YEEEEEEES
YES
'Timmy is not doing great. It would be good to talk to him and cheer him up.'
Yeah!
Why wouldn't you do that?
Why wouldn't you talk to your own child?
Maybe if he was crazy
that wouldn't be a good thing to do.
'Even a word or two may be enough to brighten someone's mood.'
'Timmy seems better by now.'
Okay.
This is good!
This is really good.
We can survive.
[Gasp] Yes!
And we don't have either of those
We can save the right thing
without losing what we don't need to lose
YEAH!!
This is going well
This is going unbelievably well
'The military is communicating through the radio'
'We're sure it was to evacuate us out of here'
'But turns out they need our help'
'The speaker requests that all able citizens'
'should chop down a tree or two in the nearby park.'
'It sounds riddiculous, but they're claiming this will make it easier for them to extract us'
'We never really liked that park so let's do this already'
Yes!
We have an axe
We can help them
We can help them help us
Help the- hel-help us
Help-help us
Alfalfa
Code name Alfalfa
Ugh
'We chopped down as many trees as we could'
'it wasn't much but hopefuly it'll make a difference they wanted'
'The next time they get in touch it better be from a tank parked on our lawn'
Okay
So
We're good
We're good for one more day
Let's see
Oh no
I'm not gonna risk this. This is a random chance
where we could get or lose two cans
I can't afford to lose two cans
And I got plenty of cans as it is.
We're fine and we don't need ANYTHING else
We're literally
FINE
♫Everyone-gets-fed-today♫
♫We-got-enough-for-25-more-days♫
♫That-would-literally-be-the-most-we've-ever-played♫
♫This-game-we-can't-go-insane♫
♫In-our-brain[Runs out of breath]we-need-to-survive♫
[High pitched] ♫This-plan-we-need-to♫
[High pitched] ♫Live-very-long♫
[High pitched] ♫It's-going-to-be-very-good♫
♫Oh my God if we don't make it this time♫
♫I will never survive♫
Oh man
Seriously if we don't make it through this time
We are in such a good place right now
If we don't make it through this time
I don't know what we're gonna do
We're gonna lose our goddamn minds
Let's see
After Dolores returned form that last expedition she was complaining of a minor foot injury
it might have been her right foot or maybe her left. One of them anyway
it seemed irrelevant at the time
But now both her feet are swollen
We need to do something about it
[Singing] I'm hesitant
[Singing] to use my
[Singing] medkit on you, you
girl
[Deep sigh]
I guess we gotta do it
I dont wanna lose - I dont wanna lo-
I dont want ANYONE to go wrong
But if someone gets sick
Then we're gonna be in a lot of trouble
But I mean, she doesn't get this
Then she's probably going to die
Alright, we gotta do something
We might not
have had to do something
but
I have a funny feeling we had
to do something about that
I'm trying to keep my family
as together as possible here
So that we can SURVIVE
and Mary Jane is my
best soldier out on the field
Okay, I'm gonna -
We're not going out
There's too many bandits
There's too many bandits later in the game
We're not going out
I'm not gonna send people out
We're gonna be fine
We can survive this
We can survive this together
As a family
Bandits are at the door,
promising us the worst fate
we could imagine if we don't let them in
It's time to make a stand or surrender
I'm going to use the lock?
Cause I can give up my gun
and hopefully that will trigger
them to rescue us sooner
Right?
Yes?
Good. Okay, good
Good good good, good good good
We were able to fight off
the bandits this time, but there's guarantee
they wont come back
We need to be prepared at all costs ( times )
We didn't think that a small padlock
would be enough ( stop them )
but it discouraged them
It's good
Mary Jane is feeling safe
Everyone is just
fine
We're not going out
One of the cupboards
in the shelter was a bit shaky
so we pulled it out to give it
a new home
In the process
we discovered a secret door
Where does it lead? No idea
but let's find out
Okay!
Why the frick not?
*bullet ricocheting*
Uh..
Pew?
What's the first thing to do
when you open a door leading to
a place you don't know?
Open fire!
Bam bam!
Our bullets struck the wall
and guess what-
we hit a water pipe!
We were able to fill a few water bottles
with all the water that trickled from the
bullet holes
*laughing* Okay
Great!
Ok, first aid kit is of no use
and we need to do something about it
for some bizarre reason,
we believe we can use lethal bug-spray
to produce some additional medicine?
Maybe it'll work?
We won't know until we've tried it!
What else am I gonna do with the bug spray?
Oh my God,
It worked!
Ho - Holy shit-balls!
What the fuck?
Deadly bug-spray can result in
just enough drugs to replenish
an empty
???? ( first aid kit )
Wh - what do we do,
we just open the supply kit
and just sprayed it in there willy nilly
and it worked?
Oh my God..
Thats amazing
This is incredible
This is astonishing
Ok..
When we heard a knock at the door
we decided to open, our heart rate goes up a bit
Fortunately, this time it wasn't blood-thirsty raiders
but the brother and sister we befriended
They're  ambitious,  trying to construct a few houses
Can't help you, don't have axe
Hopefully that's not gonna screw me over later
We are not alone, there's a huge hairy bunny-beast
that seems to be hiding in one of the pipes
we can't let it be in here when we sleep
SHOOT THE SUCKER!
BANG!!
Bang, bang, bang.
Bang bang bang bang, a-bang bang
a-bang bang bang.
Shoot you dead.
Ok..
Our cans are saved! Too bad for the hairy mutant!
and we kept our gun
I'm shocked about that
Let's see..
Mary Jane .. looking fine.
Everyone's fine
God, they better rescue us soon
A gang of thugs started banging on
the door asking us to
surrender, how do we respond?
WITH A GUN TO THE FACE!!
TAKE OUR GUN!
KABANG!
Dammit, our gun broke
Hopefully that wasn't the only gun that we needed
that we needed
...trusty rifle
But maybe I can repair it with the book
That was kinda a thing that happened
before
maybe it's gonna happen again
wait
judging by the sound of gunfire
and screams, it seems like a band of
thugs has taken control of the area,
going out could be very risky
Yeah, we're not gonna DO that
we got - we're fine
we got another 15 days ahead of us
we always steered away from casinos, gambling
dens and the like
so when a man came to our door and told us
he used to be a gambler
... two watter bottle bet -
we dont need it.
we don't need the water, we got more than enough water
water's not our problem
I wouldn't even risk it if the
food bet was there - we're not gonna do that
oh no
... group of bandits on the other side demanding
we walk out with our hands up
Oh, God dammit!
*frustrated growl*
*yelling* Ohh, what!? No!!
*yelling* man!
Ohhh...
... we hope nothing BAD will happen to 'em...
... grabbed Ted and took him away ...
Oh, God dammit...
gang of firefighters
... dressed like it ...
... surrender all of our supplies ...
... drive us out with FIRE if we don't comply
*yelling* WHAT IS THIS BULLSHIT?
*yelling* OH WHAT THE FUCK??
*dies for a second*
*high pitched scream*
if I didn't trade the bug-spray
for medicine, I -
*yelling* THIS GAME IS IMPOSSIBLE!
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE!
I DID EVERYTHING RIGHT
I DID EVE-RY-THING RIGHT
I DID EV -
WHY DIDN'T I GET RESCUED?
WHY?
I HAD EVERYTHING!
IT WAS LIKE AN UNSTOPPABLE
CHAIN OF MADNESS
STOPPING US FROM SUCCEEDING !!
*high-pitched scream*
*frusturated growl*
is this game actually possible?
is this game ACTUALLY possible -
is it possible -
why is there a pizza on the God damn roof?
why uh -
is that a reference to Breaking Bad?
*sigh*
it's - it's impossible
it's possible - I know, I know it's possible
I know it's possible
I know it's possible but
God dammit
have you ever seen such
a string of bad luck
befall a player of this game
up until this point right here?
that is absurd
I had everything in the palm of my hand
everything was going swimmingly for me
everything was BEAUTIFUL
and then I lost it all?
was it because I wasn't going on enough exp -
I was playing it safe!
there were bandits EVERYWHERE!!
everywhere, there were bandits
It's not like I would've gotten the supplies I needed
Ugh..
Why did my gun have to blow up?
Oh well
I think that's enough 60 seconds for me...
I don't know when I'm gonna come back to this
Maybe I'll livestream it until I beat it
That'll be a more INTERESTING way to
get to the END of the game
than what we've done thus far
But thank you everyone so much for watching
let me know what ways I went wrong
in the comments
and as always, I will see YOU, in the next video
buh bye!!
*Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan plays*